if we Freedom Fighters do not get United  to end dictatorship dictators will get  United to end us and democracy on  October 3rd 2022 the human rights  Foundation held a one-day conference at  Town Hall in Midtown Manhattan bringing  together political activists from around  the world Thor Halverson is the  organization's founder and CEO the  United Nations is a massive club for  dictators the rich powerful and corrupt  get-together in dollars well some of the  world's bravest people get together at  the office of Freedom Forum they then  start trading ideas  Syria China  Zimbabwe Hong Kong  Russia human rights is basically limits  on government power  [Music]